[Music]  mama June dropped 300 pounds and now  she's flaunting her new bikini bod the  37 year old channeled her best  Baywatch lifeguard while modeling in  this figure hugging red swimsuit June  has been hard at work on her beach bod  going from 460 pounds to a size 4 and  documenting her weight-loss journey on  from not too hot I will never go back to  what Ella lied when et sat down with the  mother of four following the dramatic  change  mama June vowed to maintain her new  lifestyle I will do whatever it takes  you have to exercise you have to  maintain hell under well think think  that when you have a surgery's that is  system nothing else has to be done and  that is not the case is it a living  Lauren thing